we have two western conference wizards
the connoisseurs of clutch
i'm talking about the long-range legends
steph curry
versus dame lillard they're both
talented but only one of them will be
crowned
the champion of one-on-one today's
categories are
game breaker ankle breaker back breaker
which is our surprisingly great category
buzzer beater and big man beaver this
episode of one-on-one is presented by
state farm when it comes to insurance
you can get the personalized service of
a local agent for a surprisingly great
rate of state farm
let me introduce my co-host my guide
podcast superstar nba veteran
q rich what's up baby building you
already know ready for this one let's
get it
let's get right into it our special
guests for today nba champion
lights out shooter and the guy who made
wearing a face mask
during the nba games cool make some
noise from my man
hamilton what's up rip yeah i appreciate
it love to be a part of this man you
know you two guys are my guys man
like i said i should have came on air
with my mask now that everybody in the
world is wearing them so
i wouldn't look crazy if i had it on
during the interview did you have to
respect back then because now it's
considered cool right but
oh you got it on you oh listen man i
keep this thing very close to me man
this is like my batman cake right here
man this
this one this little boy said
a lot of people a lot of people don't
even know what number i wear but they
know i wear this pass i'll tell you that
right
the first uh category is game breaker
we're going to start with steph y'all
ready here we go yes sir all right the
game is tied this is an overtime
game winner from 2016.
this is crazy how do you guard that like
like
literally like you you know that like as
as a defender
you know you learn to get back to the
looking you can't run the rush brussels
russell's face
facial expression says everything like
that
can't say what i want to say but what
the that ain't
that ain't supposed to be in the
scouting report right there you got to
pick up a man as soon as he come across
half
right there that's just unlimited that's
something right there that we haven't
looked he
he never seen dancing that's one where
you gotta
rip you know what you gotta do you gotta
trip him you gotta take him out you came
when he like a video game out there man
you can't
godly yeah that's kind of before it was
normal for these boys to really be
pulling up from there like this was like
on the cusp it's
a big being like a thing like they
weren't just shooting them regularly
like they are now
but when this when it's steph curry man
listen as soon as he takes one step over
that half foot line
man you might as well start battling
with him doing the little shimmy
because it's a high chance that shot
going in here it is here it is here it
is
yeah yeah what's wrong with him
i feel you rice all right let's move on
to james clip
the walk-up though the walk-up though
kill like when a man just walking you up
and just sizing you up
coming by half court man hey you you got
to slap the floor two times and you got
to figure out a way
to get up any man i mean that right
there bro
just look at this scene right here is
ill right here
step back to the side you size him up
everybody in the
in the whole gym know that hey it's only
a couple seconds on the shot clock paul
george right there
i mean when he came after the game and
said hey good game i mean that was
like a bad shot i was one of them guys
that said hey man paul maybe
that was a bad shot but but not the dame
though
this sent them home this ended the
dissent child fishing
this was it this is a playoff close out
game when the series over and when he
walk off and say bye bye that mean i
ain't gonna see
people the next year i mean y'all go
ahead and pack it up
go on some of it get to your summer
houses get your trainers and duke listen
that was cold-blooded the best part
about it was when the meme came
everybody
was demonia about me
thank you to me the meme was even
crazier
everybody was losing it and it was like
he was like he was just
still in the moment like he was still in
the moment it's top five all the time in
my opinion bro
i i ain't wow i ain't seen nothing like
that man i was like
and we played the game my my draw is
dropped like you know it's one of them
players right there to be like yo
you are you kidding me like rip let's
start with you between the two clips
steph versus dame we're only choosing
the best highlight
who do you choose hands down i mean
steph is one of the best shooters of all
time i mean the shot was big time you
you can see this expression right there
like yo come on man
but what dang did man because he
actually
sized him up like usually when a guy
comes down the court and size you up you
got to smack the floor get up
you got to do something but he was able
to knock that down in that pressure
moment and like you said send him home
man i'm going with dame dollar just to
make this show
interesting i'm going with steph cause i
want to see what hugh rich has to say
i'm going with steph on this one i
really love that dame clip i
completely agree with you rip cue
but look this one listen like you said
when we ran the clip it was
it was during the regular season and
this
is during the playoffs in a series that
where they was talking trash it was beef
it was a little back and forth
that was actually a good defense the man
shot it from 10 feet behind the line
and then you still had a 6 7 6 8 dude
still get a good contest like
paul george did like i wouldn't have
been no closer than he was and he still
got a long
reach on it like that's just ridiculous
dawg
i think this one is a no-brainer the the
the game breaker category is hands down
going to dame
lillard i completely agree this is a
moment right here
this is a moment it's just this is i got
no watch on
but you cannot beat this i'm sorry steph
not this time
this category goes today all right let's
move on to the next category the next
category is ankle breaker speaks for
itself let's start with step
okay here we go oh oh
oh man oh oh oh cp
he was trying to get some content on
that contact on that play right there
i love cp3 but i do remember the memes
from this play
they had they had him break dancing
oh yeah you know cp man as a defender
man cp
very similar like john stockton man he's
going to get up in you
and he's going to take chances but that
wasn't the chance that cp wanted to take
right there on that boy right there i'll
tell you that
that thing it happened too fast
that was a behind-the-back pop-pop all
right let's move on to dame
let's see what we got oh
that that that's that's that's one of
those things right there that happened
in the game you come back in the locker
and be like yo bro yeah i mean that's a
legit
true but i mean it was just kind of like
look why
that's what make it so bad because the
way he tripped
all right it's time to get our votes in
what are y'all this this is actually a
tough one
i'm going with steph we're going with
dame rip we're starting with you
i i'm going i'm gonna have to go with
steph
and the reason why is because i know how
important
cp takes challenges on playing against
the great guards stuff like home bro
this ain't the old way of playing
basketball man i'm
a lot more creative with this ball hand
this skill
and he caught cp off guard so i'm going
with the step
i got to be honest this is the ankle
breaker category
and i feel as though that dame lillard
crossover both parties went separate
ways simultaneously it was disgusting
that man got up his thumb he didn't know
what was going on
i gotta go with dame on this one come on
christian i think you just
you're just trying to go against me
every time that i
that i say something you just like
you're just going to the complete
opposite really
really i'm going to say this i'm going
to say this the first the first time i
did but this time no i'm actually going
with dave on this one i'm with dame on
this
okay all right q alright so here we go i
gotta be the tie breaker yet again
you got two of the the most elite point
guards
in the game up against each other and
this and this
actual play is mano imano and like rip
said it was cp doing what he'd do
he's just pursuing and getting it to him
and steph caught him
caught him slipping because he like with
the cp's credit if cp wasn't playing
that hard step couldn't have got him
like this
so he got him like this and then well
what i remember the most i remember
kevin hart i remember the means on the
end
they had pictures and means of cp break
dancing like a pack of the day on the
disco board like this brought the
cardboard out brother cardboard
yes this was crazy i gotta go with the
stuff play right here
takes this category as the w and once
again i'm wrong i'm the only one on this
island
our third category is called backbreaker
which is our surprisingly great category
this is when a play looks like it's
not going so well but then ends up being
surprisingly
great
this just doesn't make sense the best
part of the video for me
was that his coach was pissed see kurt
went like this it wasn't a happy one of
these
when he and this one
went in he turned around so i can't even
yell at him right now because he made it
look
[Applause]
the most amazing thing to me about this
shot
is that he took it i could never even
what killed him yeah she'll be so bad
but i could think of four five different
coaches i played for where it wouldn't
even enter my
inner matrix to even think about doing
something like that i think after what
he did with the ball he went through
about four five players behind the hole
between the legs behind him back then
just turned around just threw it up
[Laughter]
but i gotta say he's undefeated with the
humble brag celebrations
like steph really knows how to like do
it respectfully but still show you like
he knows he's never respectful
i don't yeah it's so disrespectful
respectfully because it's this little
smiling nice
guy but
[Music]
somebody tweet him something he go do it
in the second half like
take a look at damon's clip and see what
he has
oh my god come on man
that's so disrespectful hey look i
thought he was about to dunk it for a
minute the way he first turned like
oh yeah that was the look i'm the black
cat cat
he really got like first of all jason
smith got scored on like
four different times in that play heap
on the drive that was gonna go and it
got taken on the first layup that was
him
look he came off didn't pick up on the
figure got blown by
take it out of bounty he threw it back
to him now he's about to get
bodied and one day he bought the stream
and look nerd over there he like give
him nerve
that's when the jeep that's when the gm
look and say hey man we gotta get
somebody
gotta get a security blanket some
somebody that can
can guard the basket man right there now
we just ain't gonna have a dude that
sticks to get flex on you give us two
back-to-back plays like that y'all
making this one tough for me because you
know me real this was the type of play i
took pride in making going inside
getting offensive rebound against the
big just going to end one and flexing
and talking so
y'all to make this one difficult for me
rip you know we starting with you
what do you think i'm i'm going even
both on was amazing play
but i i gotta go with steph curry man i
mean to come in the pick and roll
situation right you got three defenders
uh in right around the free throw line
and you got one of the best defenders
in cp again you know chasing him down
and the ability to get that shot off
effortless
not a throw but still being able to
square up
and get that thing off and then come
down the shimmy and then looking at the
business like oh this is
like these guys got me messed up this is
what i do man i'm going with steph
i'm going with steph curry let's mix it
up q what you got you go next
i gotta go with steph oh i gotta go with
steph
like listen man the play like the play
it should not have happened exactly
talking about the way we play basketball
like you're not supposed to be
allowed to do this this is something
that you would do
in a video game and you know whoever you
playing with all right you riley now i'm
about to really whoops
like playing with me like this hey i
couldn't even shoot this kind of shot
bro
you feel me a i could shoot any kind of
shot he hey i wouldn't end up it just
never entered his mind to do what did
this man just did like
and he we ain't never seen that i do
that like oh this was
crazy steph curry just won the back
breaker category
and for what it's worth i actually for
the first time today agreed with y'all i
was gonna break
come on christmas can i can y'all give
me my flowers for that because i totally
agree
thank you thank you thank you steph gets
that one which puts him in the lead on
this one-on-one battle
let's see what dame does in this next
category this one is called the buzzer
beater which we know both of these guys
have a ton of
here's stuff i remember this one man
tough cooking up some playoff magic here
misses it three but then just does
something that makes zero sense
[Music]
tough the way that man the way to do
moves without the ball because anytime a
dude shoots a shot
you think he already just standing in
the same spot q or he going the other
way
but that dude is already when that ball
goes up he's trying to get to another
spot on the floor to get that shot off
the shot was an one bro they did not
call it
he crashed into the kid's body look at
this look at how he shot it and didn't
try to protect himself cause he's about
to get crashed into it
he's got two hands in his face that was
anthony davison
who else they crashed into him come on
bro he he probably didn't even see the
rim on that shot right here that's what
i'm saying like he
literally got body tackles
that's a body tackle he got russian
sickled on that plate
right hit him with the lariat
yes he did nothing about this make
any sense to me how did they not call a
foul on that though now that i'm
watching it
at the moment it was they were
spectating at that point
they were just as amazing right there
like really i thought that
i thought that he was gonna block that
shot that's what the referee is looking
at
this is a hard one to beat now a few
players have eliminated on a buzzer
beater shot
in the playoffs but dame has managed to
do it more than once
let's take a look at this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is game set match good night oh my
goodness
yeah don't forget to tip your waitresses
there you ain't coming back
this week uh and the crazy part about it
man
the dude is going left most most
right-hand dominant shooters they
want to come uh shooting off the right
side but he's going left
away from the best it still gets his
come on man
like come on man that's that's clutch
clutch
that's different like are you different
you different bro that's when you go
back
live where we say yo bro you different
you different this is the toughest call
of the day for me
because this was a series close out shot
it i have to go with it because what it
meant
it sent somebody home it said like
literally after this game
you could go turn on tnt and ernie and
them was putting on their head and doing
the gun fishing charles and all of them
like they he
they he sent them fishing though that's
that's
that's gotta be one of the most
cold-blooded feelings to have
not to just because you know i mean a
lot of people here game winners were
like bro
to to to send somebody home
and that's called right there i gotta i
gotta go with dang man i'm throwing it
the rip rip you gotta
you throwing it to me i'm i'm i'm
choosing a tie
i don't know if i'm allowed to do it but
i'm doing it anyway i know where rip
going he about to do the right thing
anyway
help me out no i i like like like you
said i
i agree this was probably the toughest
one to judge between between the two
but you know steph had an amazing shot
but that was the second shot
that he was able to take and you know
the one that dame had was the like
everybody in the building
knew that this was damn time like every
like
coach says it's like when you when
you're on the opposing team coach says
hey i don't care if anybody else gets
this last shot
but dame don't get it so for them
to come off that with what one or two
seconds left to send them home and go on
left and fade on it
and the one thing about dane he don't
say a lot after making shots he just sat
there looked at you like
like like really like y'all y'all let me
get the last shot
come on bro i'm i'm going i'm going with
dave we got to clap it up for dame y'all
let's give it up for dane he pulled
through in the one-on-one battle and now
we're back to being tied up between
steph and dame
which means we got one more category to
make it all happen
now it's a
big
[Laughter]
okay i know you the best i know you're
one of the premier defenders in the lead
i don't care
i didn't look like it in this play
that's tough right there i don't know
what you're going to do right there rudy
i mean look they they left female out on
the island right there
like come on man try to come in and help
but then he got caught up in the play
now you
got biscuit all right listen that does
happen too sometimes you get caught up
when when it happens to one of your
teammates sometimes you get caught up in
the play
and that right there looked like his
other four teammates got caught up in
the play and was like yo man did he just
do that
let's see what dame does
he's taking on draymond he got iggy and
draymond
yeah he got him both when they got him
right there
that's when you when it happened
christian where you going where are you
going with this where are you going with
this oh
yeah right now first oh
my god this episode all right
i gotta give it to steph for making rudy
do
the macarena turn yourself around that's
what it's all about
like he had this man doing every uh
dance that you do in a club on the court
he had him do a circle spin cycle he did
his laundry
he he he made this man dance
i gotta get it to step i mean for you to
be able to make someone do
a full is this that's 720 is that 720.
yeah i'm going with steph and with that
being said i think the next vote
should go to rip man listen
i know q has to agree with me on this
one i mean come on man
like this man like you said he made him
do a 720 like
like this is rudy gobert i'm going with
steph curry bro
q is this a sweep
even though my choice does not matter
because steph has already been
deemed the winner i too
have to go with steph curry
let me say why let me say why because
this is like
like rip said this is defensive player
of the year
uh first team all defense all those
different things seven
seven three seven two however tall he is
and i'm talking about steph came out
there
and he looked like he from chicago right
now because he got that man doing
work he looked like he he worked at uh
when we grew up they had public access
and he
did so called stepping at club seven now
that boy looked like he was stepping
well you know i'm gonna go ahead and
give steph his love
man step step got got this one with this
one man sorry head i hate it had to be
you rudy
tower goes down on this one gotta love
rudy but
steph did it to him which gave him the w
which means steph
is the champion of one on one can we
clap it up for my man
steph curry wow
i'm really happy for i'm really i'm
really happy for steph for getting this
w
um i just want to say uh thank you guys
both for joining me as
always rip been absolutely amazing thank
you for putting in your votes and having
a wonderful time with us q
you're the man i always appreciate
everything you already know
and everybody watching until next
episode
tune in once again to 101 presented by
state farm
that's a wrap yes sir this episode was
brought to you by state farm
like a good neighbor state farm is there